my biggest learning of even the last
year to two years of my career has been
packaging if you look at McConaughey
when you went from rom-com rom-com
rom-com shirtless shirtless shirtless he
basically like disappeared from the
scene and then came back and like did
Dallas Buyers Club and like all these
other movies where he took like serious
roles on Etc and I think that like for
me it was like I was making all gym
stuff I wanted to push myself away from
all gym stuff and I kind of slumped to
the background only thing I produced at
that point was the podcast which I'd
rebranded as the game but I still wasn't
doing anything else that was public and
that was like a year or two and then I
started making content publicly so I
feel like sometimes you have to like
give a little bit of distance or like
give a little space so they're like kind
of like reset go out with like whatever
the new kind of Direction you want to go